ELIAS PINTO: Hello, and
welcome to Google Cloud On Air.
These are the live
webinars from Google Cloud.
Today, we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Elias Pinto.
And with me, I have--
SARA ROBINSON:
I'm Sara Robinson.
ELIAS PINTO: We're
based out of New York.
And today, we will be
talking about AutoML Vision.
To let you know, you can
ask questions any time
on the platform, and we
have Googlers on standby
to answer them.
So let's get started.
So here is Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Elias.
So today, we're going to
talk about AutoML Vision,
making custom image analysis
possible for every business.
Before we get into
that, let's talk
about what machine learning is.
So at a high level,
machine learning
involves teaching computers
to recognize patterns
in the same way
that our brains do.
Over time, as machine learning
models are given more examples
and experience, they're able
to improve and generalize
on the input that they
haven't seen before.
So does anybody
remember how they
learned their first language?
Your parents probably
didn't give you
a dictionary and a bunch of
grammar books to memorize.
That'd be kind of weird.
Instead, you learned over
time by being exposed
to many different examples.
So let's say you were
having pasta for dinner.
You saw it on your plate.
You heard your
parents identify it.
Maybe you identified it
incorrectly a few times
and were corrected.
Over time, this repetition
strengthens certain pathways
in your brain.
And this is roughly how
machine learning works too.
So at a high level,
machine learning
is loosely based on how
the human brain learns.
Instead of biological
neurons, we
have mathematical
neurons that mimic
these neurons in our brain.
With machine learning,
we can solve problems
without exactly knowing
what the solution might be.
And finally, machine
learning enables
systems that improve
over time as they're
given more and more data.
So before I start solving
a machine learning problem
and picking the tool
I'm going to use,
I like to think about the type
of ML problem that I'm solving.
And on Google Cloud
Platform, we have a spectrum
of machine learning offerings.
So on the left-hand
side, we have
products that are targeted more
towards application developers.
If you're new to
machine learning
and don't have any machine
learning experience,
we offer five pre-trained APIs.
These give you access to
pre-trained machine learning
models.
All you need to
do to access them
is make one REST API request.
On the right side
of the spectrum,
we have products that are
targeted more towards data
scientists and those with
a little bit more machine
learning experience.
And for this, we have TensorFlow
for building your own machine
learning models and ML
Engine as our managed
platform for TensorFlow.
So going a little
bit deeper into this,
if you've got a
common classification
task that someone else
has solved before,
you don't need to
start from scratch.
You don't need to build a model
from scratch, trained only
on your own data.
You can utilize existing
pre-trained models
that are out there.
But if you've got
a problem that's
very specific to
the type of data
that you're dealing
with at your company,
it's probably going to be a more
custom task that you'll need
a more customized solution for.
So let's take image
classification as an example.
Let's say you want to
identify that there's
a cat in this image.
And you've probably heard
this example before.
This has been done
many times before.
There's lots of
models that exist out
there that have been trained
on hundreds of thousands
of images that can tell you
if there is a cat in the image
or not.
So there's no need to start
from scratch, although you
can if you'd like,
but it's fastest
to utilize a pre-trained
model that's already out there
to help you with this.
But let's say, for example,
that this is your cat.
Its name is Chloe.
And you want to
identify Chloe apart
from other cats in
your image data set.
So this is a more custom task.
You're going to need to train
a model on your own data
using label data so that
it can identify Chloe apart
from other cats and animals
in your image library.
So let's start with the
machine learning APIs.
We offer five
different APIs that
give you access to
a pre-trained model
to accomplish common
machine learning tasks.
So you don't really
need to know anything
about how these models work
under the hood to get started.
You just pass in your image
data for the Vision API,
for example.
You get back the classification.
The Video API does what
the Vision API does
for images, but for videos.
It lets you analyze videos.
The Speech API lets you perform
speech-to-text transcription.
With the Natural
Language API, we
can further analyze that text.
And with the translation
API, we can translate text
into over 100
different languages.
So these are our
pre-trained APIs
targeted towards
application developers who
want to integrate
machine learning
into their applications.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
we have tools to help
you build and train
your models from scratch.
So from the beginning,
the Google Brain team
wanted everyone in
the industry to be
able to benefit from all of
the machine learning projects
that they were working on.
So they made TensorFlow, an
open source project on GitHub.
And the uptake has
been phenomenal.
TensorFlow is the most popular
machine learning project
on GitHub.
Last time I checked, I think it
had over 90,000 GitHub stars.
It also just crossed
over a million downloads.
It's being used
all over the world.
And because TensorFlow
is open source,
you can train and serve your
TensorFlow models anywhere.
Because we're focused on
Google Cloud Platform today,
I'm going to talk
about our managed
platform for TensorFlow.
This is called Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
And it lets you take advantage
of distributed training.
You can distribute your
training job across machines,
using GPUs or TPUs to
accelerate your machine learning
workloads.
Once your model's
trained, you can then
choose to deploy it to Machine
Learning Engine for serving.
So let's say your ML
model becomes a huge hit.
You're getting thousands
and thousands of prediction
requests every second.
You're going to
need a scalable way
to handle all those requests.
And you can use Machine Learning
Engine to serve your model.
The great thing about ML
Engine is there's no lock in.
You can choose to train
your model on ML Engine
and then download it, export
it, and serve it somewhere else.
Optionally, you
can train the model
wherever you'd like and
decide you want to serve it
on Machine Learning Engine.
Another thing I like
to think about when
I'm diving into a
machine learning problem
is the resources that I
need to solve that problem.
I've listed just four here.
There's probably others
that I haven't thought of.
But let's go over
what these are.
So first is training data.
How much training
data are you going
to need to get an accurate model
that's going to get an accurate
prediction on your data?
How much model code
are you going to write?
How much training and
serving infrastructure
are you going to
have to provision?
And then, finally,
overall, how much time
is this whole process
going to take you?
So let's look at how this
applies to the products
that I've talked about so far.
So if you look at machine
learning as an API,
the great thing
about these APIs is
that you don't need any
training data to use them.
The model has
already been trained.
They're pre-trained models.
So if I wanted to, I could
just generate a prediction
on a single image.
I pass that image to the API.
I get a prediction back.
But it didn't require any
of my own training data.
I also don't need to write
any of the model code.
Again, that's all handled
for you by the API.
An API is available on
Google Cloud Platform.
So I don't need to worry
about training or serving
infrastructure.
All it's going to take
is a little bit of time
to write my request to
the API and figure out
how I want to parse the
response that I get back.
You can get up and
running with these APIs
in probably less than a day.
Now, we'll talk
about two approaches
to building a custom model.
The first is transfer
learning, which
lets you take advantage
of a model that's already
been trained to do a similar
task to what you'd like to do.
So let's say you want identify
where certain objects are
in an image.
There's lots of models that
have been trained to do this.
So you can utilize the weights
of these trained models
and then just modify the
last couple of layers,
based on your own training data.
So with this, you will need
some of your own training data
because the predictions
are going to be
specific to your data set.
You will need to write
some of the model code,
and you may need to
think about provisioning
training or serving
infrastructure.
Or you may choose to use a
managed service for this.
And this will obviously
take a little bit more time
than the pre-trained APIs.
And then finally, if you've
got a model built entirely
from scratch, trained
only on your data,
you're going to need a lot
of training data for this
to work successfully.
You're also going to need to
write a lot of the model code
yourself, think
about where you're
going to run your
training, and how
you're going to serve
your model and production.
And obviously, this one
will take even more time
than with transfer learning.
So focusing specifically
on image analysis,
let's take a look at
the existing tools
for image analysis on
Google Cloud Platform.
For that, we have
the Cloud Vision API,
which lets you perform image
analysis with a single REST API
request.
These are all of the features
that the Vision API provides.
So at its core, the Vision
API offers label detection,
which will tell you what
is this a picture of.
So for this image, it might
return elephant, animal,
et cetera.
Then we have web detection,
which goes a step further.
And it will look across the
internet for similar images.
And then based on the
content of those pages,
it will provide
additional details
on what's in your image.
Then we have OCR or Optical
Character Recognition.
OCR is able to extract
text from images.
So if any of you have ever
used the Google Translate
app before, and taken
a picture of a sign,
and then seen the
translation in real time,
you can use the Vision
API's OCR method
to implement similar
functionality
into your own applications.
Logo detection will identify
common logos in an image.
Landmark detection we'll
find landmarks in an image.
Crop hints can help
you crop your photo
to focus on specific
subjects in the image.
And then finally, we have
explicit content detection.
This is pretty self-explanatory.
It will tell you is your
image appropriate or not.
This one is pretty
useful across the board
for any site or app that
has user-generated content.
Instead of having
someone manually review
all of those images
that come in,
you can send it
to the Vision API,
and then maybe you
only need to review
a subset of those images.
As I mentioned, the
Vision API is a REST API.
So you can call it in
any language you'd like.
The example code I have
here is in Node.js.
And on Google Cloud
Platform, we have a number
of client libraries in
your favorite language
that make it easy to
call all these APIs.
So I'm using the Google Cloud
node module for the Vision API.
Here I tell it the types
of detection I want to run.
I call detect on
that Vision object.
I can either pass it
a local image URL,
or I can pass it the URL of
a file stored in Google Cloud
Storage.
I can also just pass it the raw
image content, Base64 encoded.
So I pass it that image,
the types of detection I
want to run.
And then I get a response
back with the detections.
And I can analyze
that response however
I'd like to use that
data in my application.
So I don't like to get too
far into a presentation
without showing a live demo.
So I'm going to
bring Elias on here
to show us a demo of Vision API.
ELIAS PINTO: Thank you, Sara.
So here we have a chance to
actually see how powerful
the Cloud Vision API really is.
And to build on
what Sara just said,
It gives the ability to
understand what's in an image.
And Google is very
uniquely positioned
to provide you with powerful
machine learning models.
And let me show
you how easy it is.
This is a publicly available
demo that you can do.
And we're going to go
and actually pull up
some images here.
So Sara was kind enough to
share some of her recent holiday
pictures, and we pulled up a
picture she took in Poland.
And right away, what you see is
that the machine or the model
immediately recognized that
this was taken in Krakow.
Or if you're Polish, I think
you pronounce it "Krakoff."
And it not only
recognizes that landmark,
but it's able to find out
that it's also the main market
square.
And because of
Google Maps, we were
able to pull exactly
the lat/long of where
that picture was taken.
Let's look a little bit
more into the other labels
that we have, the other
entities that we recognize.
So we recognize the face.
Here we see the human
face is picked up.
But also, please note,
the exact location
of things, like eyes, nose, and
mouth, is correctly identified.
We're able to also determine
sentiment analysis.
So Sara here looks very
joyful and even surprised
at that picture.
And as you can see
there, very likely,
those are the emotions she is
displaying on that picture.
It must have been a fun holiday.
SARA ROBINSON: It was.
ELIAS PINTO: So
we can quickly see
there is a very
long list of labels
that we automatically
assign to that picture.
And we're able to see that
under the web entities,
we were able to
use the knowledge
of the web about that
picture and actually pull it.
And it does an image
search and compares
that with the information
available on the web.
I'll briefly mentioned here
that we also have Safe Search.
We can very quickly identify
that, yes, this is just
a plain holiday picture, and
it's safe to show at any age.
The last thing I want to
show is the JSON output.
It's a very long
output, but I'll just
highlight some of the
types and positions
of the different labels.
So you can see the left eye,
the right eye, and so on and so
forth for each one of the labels
that it identified, it pulls.
It gives you exactly where
it is located on the image.
Let's pull up another image,
and this one is a little busier.
Sara, again, was very lucky
to have gone to "Hamilton--"
the show very recently--
so she shared a picture.
As you can see, this is
a much busier picture.
There's a lot more going
on, a lot more different
labels and other
elements in this picture.
So under faces, right away, we
picked her face here, again,
with a sentiment analysis.
Now here's the interesting bit.
We can show things
like on the web,
it recognized correctly this
was the Richard Rodgers Theatre.
And under text, I don't
know if you noticed,
but the word "playbill" is
actually in the bottom there.
This highlights the intelligence
around OCR that we have.
Even if there's multiple
words in the picture,
we're able to
extract that to you.
If it's a piece of text
under the document,
say it's a menu, or
a form, or a resume,
we're able to pick
different blocks of text
and display them under
pages and blocks.
So these are some of the things
that we wanted to highlight.
The good thing is that this
is a publicly available under
a cloud.google.com/vision.
And you may test this
on your own today.
A quick reminder, if I may.
If you want to ask
questions, we ask you
that you put those questions
throughout our presentation,
so we're able to bubble them up
towards the end of our session.
Back to Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you, Elias.
Great demo.
So back to the slides.
I want to revisit the
ML spectrum that I
covered in the beginning.
So remember that on
the left-hand side,
we have products targeted
towards app developers, machine
learning APIs.
These are pre-trained APIs.
You can't customize
them at all, but they're
very easy to get up
and running with.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
we have products targeted
towards data scientists
and machine learning
practitioners.
And these allow you a
lot more flexibility
in building a custom model
trained on your own data set.
So this is what the spectrum
looked like until just a couple
of months ago.
I'm super excited
about this new product
that we announced in
January called AutoML.
The first product under
AutoML is AutoML Vision.
And it's currently
in alpha so you need
to be whitelisted to use it.
But what AutoML does
is, you can see,
it clearly fills a
gap in the spectrum.
What it does is AutoML Vision
lets you customize the Vision
API to your own data set.
So let's say the Vision API
works pretty well for you,
but you've got some
very specific images
that you wouldn't expect it
to recognize what they are,
but you want to generate
labels, based on your company's
very specific data set.
Now you can do that with AutoML.
So this is what AutoML
Vision provides.
It's essentially a
UI that helps you
with every step of building your
model, from importing the data,
labeling it, training a
model, evaluating how well it
performed, and then
finally, making predictions
on that model, using data
that it hasn't seen before.
So the best way to
show you AutoML Vision
is to jump right into a demo.
So for this demo, let's say
that I am a meteorologist.
Maybe I work at a
weather company,
and I want to predict
weather trends and flight
plans from images of clouds.
So this begs the
question, can we
use the cloud to analyze clouds?
The answer, as you
probably guessed, is yes.
So as I was preparing
this demo, I
didn't know much about
actual clouds before.
So I learned a lot.
And I learned that there are
many different types of clouds,
as you can see
here, and they all
indicate different kinds
of weather patterns.
So my first thought was to try
this out with a Vision API.
I took a bunch of these
different cloud images
and sent them to the Vision
API to see what I got back.
Now for us, it's easy to
see, as humans, that these
are completely different
types of clouds,
but the Vision API was trained
on a huge variety of labels
to recognize high-level
things, so it
knows that there are
clouds in these images.
But even though these images are
very different types of clouds,
we get similar labels
back from the Vision API.
So this is where AutoML
Vision comes to the rescue.
So let's see a demo
of AutoML Vision.
Go back to the demo.
And what we have here is
the UI for AutoML Vision.
So as you can see, it
takes us through each step
of building our model, from
importing data, label, train,
evaluate, and predict.
So the first step here
is to import our data,
and there's a couple
of ways to do this.
We can put all of our images
in Google Cloud Storage,
and then we need to create a
CSV, where the first column
will be the URL of that image.
The second column
will be the label
associated with that image.
Now we can also
build models that
have multiple labels for
images for one image.
Then you just add extra
columns to the CSV
for that particular image.
So in this case, I've already
uploaded all of my data
and trained the model.
So let's see what happens
here in the labeling step.
So here is where I can
review my image labels.
So I can see what I have
assigned each image.
This data set, I've
already labeled.
So this, for example,
is a cumulus cloud.
We've got a cirrus cloud here.
Let's say I labeled
this one incorrectly.
I can click on it and
switch out the label here.
But let's say, for example,
that I did not have time
to label my data set, or
I had a giant data set,
and there was no way I would
be able to label it all.
AutoML Vision provides an
in-house human labeling
service.
So the way this works is you
provide a set of instructions
and some exemplar
images for each label
to these human labelers.
And in just a couple
of days, you'll
get back a labeled
image data set.
For this case, I already
had a label data set,
and just to look at a breakdown
of how many images of each type
of cloud I have-- here I'm
looking at five different types
of clouds.
And we can see how many
images I have for each label.
You only need 10
images per label
to start training a model.
But AutoML recommends
at least 100
for high-quality predictions.
And you'll obviously need
more, depending on what
you're trying to predict.
So the next step is
training your model.
And the great thing
about AutoML is
that you don't need to
write any of the model code.
That's handled by AutoML
for you automatically.
All we need to do is literally
just press this Train button,
and we can choose
whether we want
to train a base module or a
more complex advanced model.
I'll get into that
a bit later on.
So once I've trained
my model, I'll
get an email when it completes.
And my next step
is to go in here
and see how my model performed.
And there's a bunch of different
machine learning metrics here.
What I want to
focus on is what's
called a confusion matrix.
It looks confusing.
It's called a confusing matrix.
But it's actually
not that confusing.
Let's take a look.
So in ideal confusion
matrix, we want
to see a strong diagonal
down the top left, which
is what we get here.
What this is telling
us is when we uploaded
our images to AutoML, it
took a portion of them
to train the model, but then
it set aside a small percentage
of those images to see how
the model did on data that it
didn't see during training.
So this is how the model
performed on that smaller test
set of images.
So what this is telling us
is that for all of my images
that were actually
altocumulus clouds,
my model predicted 76%
of those correctly.
And we can see the percentages
we get all down here
Now for this model, I
actually trained both the base
and the advanced version.
And AutoML has a great way
to compare different versions
of your model.
So let's say even if you just
trained a bunch of versions
of the base module, let's
say you train it once
with 500 images.
Then you add 500 more images
and retrain your model,
and you want to see
how it performs.
So I can compare them here.
And now I can see how
it did on the base
compared to the advanced model.
And this looks pretty good.
It looks like all of these
went up significantly
when I went from the base
to the advanced model.
But hey, wait, this one
actually went down 12%.
And wouldn't you expect
the advanced knowledge
to perform better
across the board?
Well, what this
actually points out
is that there may be some
problems with my training data.
So if we look at
where it got confused,
it looks like it was labeling
a lot of my altostratus images
as cumulus clouds.
And I can actually
click on this,
and I can see the images that
my model was confused on.
So it turns out that
these images actually
are a little
confusing, and they may
have been labeled incorrectly.
And the advanced model was able
to identify these shortcomings
in my training data for me.
So now I can go in.
Next time I update
my model, I can
make sure to add better
images of altocumulus clouds.
So the next step-- and the
most fun in my opinion--
is generating predictions
on our trained model.
And there's a couple of
different ways to do this.
One is I can use the web UI.
So that's what I'm
going to do right now.
I can upload an
image here, and I
can see what AutoML Vision
is going to predict.
So this was indeed a
picture of a cirrus cloud,
and this is pretty awesome.
Our model is 99% confident
that this is a cirrus cloud.
So we can use the UI to
generate predictions.
This is a good quick and
easy way to check your model,
see how it's performing right
after it's been trained.
But chances are
you actually want
to build an application
that's going
to query your trained model.
And there's a couple of
different ways to do this.
I want to highlight
one in particular,
which is the Vision API.
So you saw briefly
in the past slides
what a request to the
Vision API looks like.
And what I want you
to focus on here
is that the request
really doesn't look that
much different with AutoML.
So the only things we
need to add to our request
is this custom label
detection parameter.
And then once we
train our model,
we get access to this ID
for our trained model,
and so we need to add
that to our request.
Only I have access
to this model version
or whoever else I share
this project with.
So let's say that I'm
using the Vision API.
Let's say I had
some weather app.
And first, I wanted
my app only to detect
is there a cloud in this image?
I was using the
Vision API, but then I
decided that wasn't
actually good enough.
I need to detect
the types of clouds
that I'm seeing in these images.
I don't really need to
change much about how
my app is architected.
In order for that
to work, I just
need to switch out or add
this custom label detection
parameter, along with the
model that I've just trained.
So that's how we generate
predictions on our model.
To show you how easy it
is to build an app that
uses our trained model, I built
a super simple web app here,
where I can upload
a photo of a cloud.
And we'll use this one.
And it's going to call my model.
It's going to tell me a little
bit more about that cloud.
So this is a cumulonimbus cloud.
And if you see
this type of cloud
while you're on a plane,
probably not the best sign--
might be some turbulence.
So this is just a
simple web app that
queries that model using
the Vision API, which I just
showed you, and it gives us a
little bit more data on what
these types of
clouds actually mean.
So that is AutoML Vision.
I'm going to go
back to the slides.
And I wanted to highlight
some companies that are using
AutoML Vision in production.
The first is Disney.
Disney built a model trained
to identify specific Disney
characters, products,
categories, and dominant colors
that were specific to the images
that they have in their data
set.
And they've
integrated this model
into Disney's search engine.
And it's helping their users
get more relevant results
and find their products faster.
Urban Outfitters is
a clothing company,
and they have a similar
use case to Disney.
They trained a
model to recognize
specific types of clothing
patterns and neckline styles.
And they're using that to build
a comprehensive set of product
attributes.
So through this,
they're able to improve
product recommendations, search
results, and product filters.
The last example is the
Zoological Society of London.
The Zoological Society of London
has cameras deployed all over
in the wild to identify
different types of wildlife
in their images.
And rather than having someone
manually review all the footage
that they're seeing, they
built an AutoML model
to identify all the
different types of wildlife
that they're seeing
in those images.
So I definitely encourage
you to go learn more
about AutoML Vision.
You can go to
cloud.google.com/automl.
And there you can fill out a
form to sign up for the alpha.
We're really interested to
hear what types of use cases
you have for AutoML.
There's more details
in the blog posts
where we announced AutoML.
There's also an intro
video, a podcast
that goes into a little
more detail about how
this works under the hood.
And then if you want to
try out the Vision API,
if you want to use the demo
that Elias showed earlier,
you can head over to
cloud.google.com/vision to try
that out with your own images.
I definitely
recommend doing that.
Let's say you want
to see if the Vision
API is right for your
app, but you don't
want to write any code yet.
So you can just upload
your images there,
see the JSON response
you'll get back,
and see if the
Vision API is going
to be a good fit for
your application.
So thank you, and I'm going
to bring Elias back up here.
ELIAS PINTO: So we're going
to be going into Q&A here
in just a moment.
So we we'll be back in a minute.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
ELIAS PINTO: Welcome
back, everybody.
Hopefully, you've been busy
putting some questions there.
And we've bubbled up a
couple of questions here
to get us started.
So do you want to take
the first one here?
I'll read it first.
So "how do I sign
up for AutoML?"
SARA ROBINSON: That
is a great question.
To sign for AutoML, go to
cloud.google.com/automl.
And there you'll see a
link to fill out a form.
And this is where
we're collecting
details about the use case
that you want to use AutoML.
So we'll review that, and
then you should hear back
within a couple of weeks or so.
Let's see the next question.
So you want to take this one?
ELIAS PINTO: Sure.
SARA ROBINSON: "What industries
do you see using AutoML?"
ELIAS PINTO: The cool
thing is that we are
democratizing the technology.
So really, any business
that deals with image data
and which arguably
is the vast majority,
whether it is actual
image data that has--
and specifically, I'm talking
about AutoML Vision here.
If you have to, as part of
your business, identify things.
And we talked about
Disney, about identifying
their characters, and
that intellectual property
across a very large data set.
We're able to really apply the
mature machine learning models
here to a lot of verticals,
like manufacturing, retail,
any sort of a
customer-facing applications.
There are way too many
industries here to--
I don't to limit ourselves
because even if you're just
processing resumes
or business cards,
we can do a lot to expedite
what your business does,
lower the cost of entry
because, again, it's an API.
You don't have to build
another Google data center.
We've done it.
And so you're able to just
leverage that and just
pay for what you use.
OK, let me read the next one.
So "how do I know
whether I should
use AutoML or build an
image classification
model from scratch?"
You want to do that one?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah
that's a good question.
So what AutoML excels at
is image classification.
So you give it a lot
of labeled images.
It's able to output a label
or a tag for that image.
But let's say you want to do
something a little bit more
complex, like you want to
identify bounding boxes
in your image.
So you want to say this
is a specific product
that our company
builds, and we want
to identify where
we're seeing it
in image with the bounding box.
You would need to build a
custom image classification
model with TensorFlow or
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
to do that.
Or let's say you wanted to
identify regions in an image.
That's called
masking-- so labeling
specific regions in
whatever types of images
you're labeling.
That's another use case for
a custom image classification
model.
But if you would like
to do image tagging--
so outputs and labels
based on image--
AutoML is great
across the board.
And the really cool
thing is it doesn't
require you to have to write
any of that model code yourself.
ELIAS PINTO: Awesome.
Let me read you the last
one, the next one here.
"How long does training
a model really take?
And are there any best
practices to consider in order
to speed up this process
or improve accuracy?"
Sounds like somebody really
wants to train their model.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I can take that one.
So how long does
training model take?
For the base model, I've found
it takes about an hour, maybe
a little bit less.
The advanced model
for my cloud data set,
which had about 1,500 images,
took just about two to three
hours to train.
Although as you saw in the
UI, the advanced model,
depending on how many images you
have, can take up to four hours
to train because it's a much
more complex type of model.
So it really depends
on how many images
are in your data set and the
complexity of and the variety
of those images.
Some tips to improve accuracy.
As I showed briefly, looking at
the Evaluate tab in the AutoML
UI is super useful.
I showed the confusion matrix.
There are a couple
other metrics there.
But what I love about that
confusion matrix in the UI
is that you can
actually click and see
what's being labeled
correctly, what's
being labeled incorrectly.
So I think that's the best
way to improve accuracy
on your model because
you want to remember
that your model's
only going to be
as good as the quality of
training data that you give it.
So that Evaluate tab can
help you identify problems
in your training data.
So then you can go back,
look at the matrix, and see,
OK, maybe a lot of my
data was mislabeled,
or maybe there just wasn't
enough of this particular label
category in my data set.
And you can go back
and improve it.
ELIAS PINTO: You
read the next one.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, let's
take a look at the next one.
"Once a model is built, say for
identifying a particular brand
of toy, who owns that model--
Google or the customer
who built it?"
ELIAS PINTO: This is a
really important question
to get answered.
You own your data.
That's an important point.
I'll say it again.
You own your data.
Google does not own the model.
Very important to mention that.
We do not use your data
to retrain our models.
For example, Sara showed
the cloud classification.
That the cloud
training, and the data,
and the pictures themselves
remain under Sara's ownership.
And there is a very
hard break here
that we don't use that data
or information to train
anything outside of it.
So folks that are worried
about intellectual property,
or how should I train my model?
Should I use my special sauce
with my special pictures?
There is no danger
of that getting out.
And we don't use that data to
retrain anything else outside
of your own models.
OK, I'll read the next one.
We're on the last
one on this slide.
"So I want to classify
on a type of image
or a brand, which isn't
covered by the Vision API.
What can I use to extend the
classification that is already
available through
AutoML/Vision API?"
I think you touched
on that a little bit.
You want to go back
to it a little bit?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, yeah.
I touched on that a
little bit earlier,
but I'll go back into it.
So I mentioned with
the cloud example--
so let's say that
I just want to know
is there a cloud in my image?
Vision API is great for that.
But then I wanted to go one
step further and say, OK,
what types of clouds are these?
Maybe I'm using it to build a
weather analysis application.
Then I can train a custom
model using AutoML.
Another example is,
let's say you've
got a product that's a new
product that your company's
just launching, and
you want to identify
all of the images that contain
a picture of that product.
Since it's new, the
Vision API will not
know what that specific
product is, since that's
specific to your company.
So then you can
build an AutoML model
to train it to recognize all
the images that contain that.
You could do the same with a
brand, or a logo, a new product
that you're launching.
You can build a
custom model that's
able to identify all the images
that contain that brand in it.
ELIAS PINTO: Awesome.
I think these are
all the questions
that we have bubbled up here.
So I think we're going to
move towards our closing
then, if we may.
So we have more content coming
down following this session.
So we invite you to stay tuned.
The next session is
around G Suite Security,
and they're going to be looking
at the Enterprise Mobility
Management, also the Enterprise
Security Protection, and much
more.
So thank you again for spending
the last couple of minutes
here with us.
We encourage you to
go to cloud.google.com
to go deep and wide on
some of the subjects
that we covered here today.
And thanks for spending
some time with us.
Take care.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]